police in Tempe Arizona released new
video of the deadly crash involving a
self-driving goober SUV and a pedestrian
it happened last Sunday and was the
first death involving an autonomous
vehicle the accident is once again
raising safety concerns about this new
technology and how to regulate it Kris
Van Cleave is in Washington he shows us
how investigators are still trying to
find out what caused the crash Kris good
morning good morning a couple years ago
when California blocked uber from
testing its self-driving technology on
state roads Arizona deliberately set up
a regulation light environment and
that's brought dozens of companies to
the Phoenix area but this video is
fueling those questions about how much
oversight is necessary and how ready is
the technology the accident happened in
about a second with its onboard cameras
rolling Uber's SUV was going
approximately 38 miles an hour in
autonomous mode a safety driver in case
of emergency is seen here appearing to
occasionally look away from the road
before the accident 49 year-old Elaine
Herzberg jaywalking with her bicycle is
only visible to the human eye for a
moment before she is struck and killed
Tempe Arizona police tell CBS News the
early indication from its investigation
is the accident may not have been
avoidable because Herzberg appears to
have walked directly into the SUV's path
National Transportation Safety Board
investigators are in Tempe they want to
know if the sensors and other technology
on the self-driving vehicle should have
detected Herzberg sooner than a human
and they plan to speak to the safety
driver about the moments leading up to
the crash oh this brings new jobs I hope
it brings convenience and safety
starting in 2016 Arizona Governor Doug
Ducey declared the state open for
self-driving business with little
regulation what they need to do is prove
that this technology works and if
customers can't trust their cars are
safe then they're not gonna want to get
in those cars Tim Stevens is
editor-in-chief of CNET's Roadshow if
you are I go to get our drivers license
we have to pass an eye exam for example
and show some basic understanding of the
rules of the road there are no tests
like that for autonomous cars in
existence right now and maybe that's
something that should come out of an
incident like this federal legislation
on self-driving cars is stalled in
Congress leaving the rules up to the
state's current
at least 32 cities are testing or plan
to start Stephen says the industry
worries about the impact of additional
regulation and oversight more
requirements for testing for these
vehicles that could slow this testing
down quite a bit and that could
ultimately push this technology back by
years now uber has expressed its
condolences to the victim's family says
it will cooperate with all of the
ongoing investigations uber has also
suspended all of its self-driving car
testing in the four cities where the
vehicles were operating experts do
believe self-driving cars will make the
roads safer if you look at crash stats
94% of accidents are blamed on human
error and last year an estimated 40,000
100 people died in crashes involving
human drivers
bianna and as chris said the statistics
do back up that the autonomous cars will
be safer but still they're just in the
testing process and also you see footage
like that and statistics can't compete
against when you see the footage and
people think you know a machine could
have you know didn't do the right thing
or whatever but the question is whether
a human being driving yeah with a
pedestrian coming out and in the middle
of the road like that would have what
their reaction would certainly lots of
human beings driving also text and are
distracted in the meantime the testing
person who's supposed to be monitoring
should be paying attention while they
figure all this out that's very scary
that's very troubling video to to see
that a woman lost her life and that way
watch it the most unfortunate part of
this right